Brent Morin replaces Bobby Lee imagine
imagine that oh my god that would be
horrible but would you be happy-ish
happy-ish no that's stuff if you well
you would I turn it down would you turn
it down I don't know man I'm happy with
my Showtime thing right now so I'm
really I'm betting on myself too should
be great and I believe what you just
said I need right now
if undateable asked me to replace you
yeah I would say no really yeah but you
got like no car watch at the time I had
nothing you know how's Joe and you know
Joe's gone now I don't want to be
Carlton I gotta figure out the next move
you're gonna show works with Carlton
though from Dancing with the Stars Fresh
Prince he made a resurgence overbearing
yeah he hosted something I'll tell you
when you do a multicam sitcom for long
enough you start watching other multicam
sitcoms with an appreciation he's
unbelievable as Carlton yeah watch the
way he plays Carlton yeah and he really
hit that was good what's his story did
he just drop out after fresh breath he
was too good sometimes you're too good
George Costanza too good you know yeah
you know you were telling me about that
Mary got to be just whatever yeah that's
what I just said because I saw that
documentary what was it called I forget
I saw documentary about this play it a
Broadway play that happened it was a
Sondheim play Jason Alexander as a kid
was in it oh really
yeah and he was like 15 or whatever and
so it's like a reunion documentary it's
really good I forgot what it was called
I think it's the greatest thing that
never had the greatest thing that never
had something like that no I'm gonna
have to watch yeah it's great
and it shows Jason Alexander now and
he's basically saying I'm just too
associated with Seinfeld yeah and people
don't they're kind of tired of me yeah
she just it shows him at home and trying
to figure out yeah what he wants to do
and I
is that my question is this is that you
know you you're in the biggest sitcom
yeah pretty much ever
almost Yeah right you made I'm sure he
made about two to three hundred million
dollars syndication wise Jesus is that
an odd I mean to you it is like George I
think for someone like him that maybe
right away it wasn't you know because
you want to go and do different things
especially in a creative field you're
doing something that seems like it's the
same thing every day that's one of the
reasons that you do entertainment
because you want to do something that
doesn't feel the same every day so
probably right away he's like and he
tried he had that what was it that
public speakers motivational speaker
yeah went away yeah get another try when
he was up to bat a couple of times and
it didn't work and I think now he
probably looks back and goes no I was
amazing
that was great you know cuz now he talks
about it he comes back for curb you know
yeah yeah I mean you just saw so he's
probably just sitting on one of those
[ __ ] floaty toys and his giant pool
just being like what a life
yeah but here let me see something to
you he could do plays if they're giving
me if they had given me a million
dollars an episode from a TV ok
yeah and then I didn't work from MADtv
till now yeah I don't think I'd be okay
with that
sure I think I would be really depressed
mm-hmm I think I would end up like just
walking the streets you and me on
vicodin with Matthew Perry nice yeah I
mean digging through garbage cans I mean
I don't know I mean I think that I don't
think that so you have millions of
dollars through garbage can because it's
the old money is one thing money is one
thing yeah but you always here's the
thing you always want to feel relevant
sure you always want to be a part of the
next cool thing but George Costanza will
live forever he's still relevant today
yeah I understand that but he still has
to live his everyday like he wakes up
because hey can I get a photo with you
or hey you're George Costanza is only
last for so long
Yeah right it gets to a point where you
want they want people to go do you're
killing it on that new thing
yeah yeah yeah right and then him go oh
I didn't know you could do that
yeah I'm creative the creative
motivation I totally get you know I mean
the relevancy I don't know if that just
if you try to aim for that it's hard to
stay it's you know but if you are doing
something you really like and you're
trying to make some [ __ ] yeah I mean we
live in a world now where we're not
gonna have another Seinfeld because
there's not there's too many outlets you
know so many outlets fun fun dateable
was on in the 90s I'd have millions of
dollars probably yeah but it doesn't
work yeah it doesn't that is true it's
like how do you make it well the thing
is you have options you have love then
you can go do network and do this you
know all these things so creatively you
are relevant but it's like it's funny
because in the seventies good very good
that was a very good point to late
eighties 70s in the 80s you could do The
Tonight Show
yeah and you could become a household
name it was crazy I did The Tonight Show
mm-hmm no one called me yeah I'm not
even lying no one has ever said in the
history of my career
you killed it on The Tonight Show Wow I
did The Tonight Show
that's exactly well changed Carson days
yeah yeah but it didn't do anything for
me I remember the next day my brother
wanted playing Fifa and I was looking at
my phone to see and if anyone called
yeah and no one called no one called